le spectacle que vous allez voir
s'appelle Kim Ndour
en Islande ce mot signifie mouton
les moutons islandais sont beaux
des danseuses moutons des enfants
spectateurs et acteurs des coeurs de
laine et de lumière kindour s'est avant
tout un spectacle conceptuel
tout part de des images et c'est tout
c'est comme une scénographie et ben nous
on danse avec les images en fait pour
les faire parler c'est un voyage à
travers les saisons de l'Islande et à
travers aussi
l'imagination de ces moutons comment il
voit la des quatre saisons notre
directeur artistique a fait un voyage en
Islande il est tombé amoureux de
tous les paysages et
tout qui fait tout ce qui fait partie en
fait de l'Islande et il a vu que les
moutons sont très importants
et amusant aussi
au début du spectacle chaque enfant du
public reçoit un petit cœur en laine qui
permettra de communiquer avec les
artistes sur scène lorsque le cœur
s'allume les enfants savent qu'ils
doivent monter sur scène il en découle
une connexion un jeu entre eux et des
danseuses
j'ai bien aimé quand il y avait des
explosions j'ai bien aimé ça j'ai dansé
ça t'a plu ce spectacle est-ce que tu as
aimé
quand on fait belle
après cette première représentation
prism à Élancourt la compagnie du TPO se
produira les vendredis 18 et samedi 19
janvier à l'estaminet de
Magny-les-Hameaux